[Música]
vamos a las noticias de la salud con
Natalia plazas Natalia Buen día para
usted Buenos días Ángela vamos a empezar
esta sección hablando de vacunación
porque unicef publicó justamente el día
de hoy un informe en el que evidencia la
caída en las tasas de inmunización en
niñas y niños de América Latina y el
Caribe principalmente así Ángela una
caída que unicef relata como la mayor en
30 años es un retrato bastante dramático
de la situación de acuerdo a la
publicación dos coma cuatro millones de
niños es decir uno de cada cuatro niños
y niñas menores de un año carece de sus
vacunas básicas todos estos niños en
estos momentos están ahora desprotegidos
ante enfermedades que durante décadas se
han desarrollado pues herramientas que
son justamente las vacunas para prevenir
que contraigan estas enfermedades este
informe se trata de la publicación el
estado Mundial de la infancia que es en
la mayor publicación que saca cada año
unicef y para la versión de este año
decidió centrarse en las tasas de
vacunación de las vacunas rutinarias en
todo el mundo y concretamente destinó un
apartado panamerica latina que es el que
estamos analizando en este momento tras
conocer las cifras el director Regional
de unicef lamentó estas cifras y
lamentó también el retroceso veamos
durante muchos años América Latina y el
Caribe registró una de las tasas de
vacunación infantil más altas del mundo
ahora Presenta una de las más bajas Esta
es una de las crisis de vacunación
infantil más graves que la región ha
visto en casi 30 años
una noticia lamentable es que hay más
retos en este momento frente
enfermedades que antes estaban
ilimitadas O al menos bajo control
gracias a campañas masivas de vacunación
de las últimas décadas que tasas son las
que más han disminuido Natalia bueno
relata varias tasas de hecho da
distintos índices el informe Pero
concretamente resalta algunas que son de
las más importantes las rutinarias Como
por ejemplo las dosis uno y tres de la
vacuna contra la difteria la el tétanos
y la tos ferina aprovechamos justamente
para hacer un repaso de las cifras que
ha dejado este informe la vacunación con
la dtp que es esta tercera dosis contra
la de la vacuna contra la difteria el
tétanos y la tos ferina que tenemos
marcado acá con el color naranja
evidencia una caída del 18% desde el una
caída del desde el 86% hasta el
75%
estas cifras que queda esta vacuna queda
en un 75% queda muy por debajo de las
cifras mundiales que actualmente de la
media mundial que actualmente se sitúa
en un 81% y también le queda digamos al
nivel de otras regiones que han tenido
una histórica baja vacunación como es
África Oriental que tiene una taza con
esta vacuna del 74% para la primera
dosis de esta vacuna también señala una
una caída desde un 95% hasta un 82% y
también se señala una caída en la
vacunación contra el sarampión si bien
hubo un reporte en 2018 volvió a caer en
bueno Natalia está caído en las tasas de
vacunación ha dejado evidentemente a
muchos niños sin sus dosis de
inmunización en algunos solamente tienen
las dosis necesarias para proteger de
unas mínimas enfermedades que es lo que
dice el reporte sobre este respecto sí
son dosis muy bajas concretamente el
informe de alerta sobre un indicador que
es el llamado la llamada cero dosis la
cero dosis es cuando los niños no
reciben ninguna vacuna
Igualmente la investigación destaca que
hay uno coma siete millones de niños en
estos momentos con cero dosis y también
llama la atención a que el aumento de
niños con cero dosis va muy ligado
también a los ingresos que hay en las
casas de estos niños señala
concretamente que cuando se trata de
niños con padres de altos ingresos
estas tasas disminuyen radicalmente y
cuando se trata de niños en hogares con
escasos ingres esta taza puede aumentar
hasta tres veces hay otro indicador
bastante especial y bastante
destacable y hemos preparado un gráfico
un poco para explicarlo se trata a que
la cero dosis también puede aumentar
muchísimo dependiendo del nivel de
escolarización de las madres de estos
niños si podemos ver por ejemplo en esta
graficacion podemos encontrar que cuando
las madres no tienen ningún grado de
escolarización esta tasa puede llegar a
aumentar hasta un 20% en estos niños y
sin embargo puede reducirse
drásticamente
cuando las madres llegan a tener por
ejemplo un nivel de un 6% de
pueden llegar a tener hasta un nivel de
secundaria de escolarización
Bueno sí Natalia no le quería preguntar
también por el descenso en la vacunación
en general porque no solamente Pues
digamos es la población infantil la que
se ve afectada sino que hay una parte
específico para hablar de niñas y de
mujeres sí a lo largo de la región
también se han evidenciado que ha habido
caídas en la vacunación contra el virus
de el papiloma humano recordemos que
esta vacuna ayuda a proteger contra el
cáncer de cuello uterino que es la
cuarta principal causa de muerte en
mujeres en todo el mundo
en medio pues de todas estas cifras
entre las causas que destaca el informe
están el Coby 19 también la migración
pero sobre todo la falta de voluntad
política y para cerrar Ángela podemos
decir que los científicos de este
informe llaman a que los políticos se
encuentran esta voluntad y encuentren la
forma de que los sistemas de salud
vacunen a
a todos los niños de la región y que las
tasas vuelvan a ser altas como lo fueron
durante muchas décadas claro Es que aquí
la idea es no perder las batallas ya
ganadas con las vacunaciones masivas de
los últimos años le agradezco Natalia y
nos vemos mañana con más noticias Muchas
gracias Ángela